today on the Matt Walsh show dr. Fuji
has seemed to imply that the president
should enact a national state home order
which of course would be wildly
unconstitutional
not to mention redundant and useless
meanwhile dr. Burks is lecturing
Americans for failing to follow her
instructions precisely blaming us
because the curve isn't flattening like
she thought that it would are we giving
too much power and perhaps too much
trust to the medical experts in
government and maybe the government in
general will talk about that also five
headlines including new recommendations
that we socially distance from our own
families at home and today I have the
distinct honor and privilege of
cancelling Mayor Bill DeBlasio
much-deserved we'll get to all of that
coming up let's start with this
presidents presidents Burks and Falchi
who are seem to be in many ways
basically the presidents now we're on TV
yesterday of course and they're on TV
every day all day pretty much and there
were a couple of moments with these two
that I want to go back in review first
let's look at dr. Fauci on CNN seeming
to indicate that he would support a
national state home order for from the
president for the entire country and he
doesn't say that exactly but he really
seems to be implying it listen to this
doctor thought you want to get to viewer
questions just a moment for first
knowing the signs does it make sense to
you that some states are still not
issuing stay at home orders I mean
whether there should be a federally
mandated directive for that or not that
I guess that's more of a political
question but just scientifically doesn't
everybody have to be on the same page
with this stuff yeah I think so Anderson
I don't understand why that's not
happening I as you said you know the
tension between federally mandated
versus states rights to do what they
want is something I don't want to get
into but if you look at what's going on
in this country I just don't understand
why we're not doing that we really
should be so he says he doesn't want to
get into the tension between states
rights and the federal government and
all of that well yeah he's a doctor not
a constitutional scholar also not an
economist he has an expertise in one
area unfortunately there are many more
areas that are being
and everything that's going on right now
this is not just a medical situation
there's also there's also an economic
aspect of it there's a legal aspect of
it which is why I think it's a problem
when doctors are allowed to set the
policy set the course and decide
everything there they get to decide
everything that we do but they only know
about one thing now I've I've said from
the very beginning that when it comes to
the medical scientific questions we have
no choice but to go to the people of
expertise in that area you know I don't
know much about viruses or diseases of
most of us don't and so you have to go
to sources now that doesn't mean that
you implicitly trust just one person
because they happen to be on TV all the
time but you you you look at a a
collection of different sources and
that's where you go but that's for just
that part of the problem as I said there
are many other parts very important
parts and we're not gonna go to the
doctors to tell us about that they don't
necessarily know anything about all the
other relevant factors so as far as the
doctors are concerned sure destroy the
economy destroy everybody's lives if you
have to foul she says that it's it's
just an inconvenience that's what he
said yesterday there's an economic
inconvenience he said that on the day
when it was announced that there were
six million unemployed people officially
put on the rolls last week totaling up
to ten in two weeks ten million and he
he writes that off as an inconvenience
according to his medical opinion
destroying the livelihoods of tens of
millions of Americans is an
inconvenience and it seems he also
thinks that the president acting in a
blatantly unconstitutional way and
assuming the dictatorial power to lock
330 million Americans in their home is
something that perhaps should happen and
I'm sure he would call that just a at
most state constitutional inconvenience
from his medical point of view but again
that's not a medical question his
medical point of view is irrelevant to
the constitutional question it's
irrelevant to get to the economic
question yet he's asked about these
areas anyway and he has no problem
pontificating meanwhile
here's dr. Burks at the White House
press her yesterday and she is very
upset with with all of you for screwing
things up listen to this I know you've
seen the slope in the United States
versus the slope in Italy and we have to
change that slope we have to change the
logarithmic curve that we're on we see
country after country having done that
what it means in the United States is
not everyone is doing it so we're only
as strong as every community every
county every state every American
following the guidelines to a tee and I
can tell by the curves and as it is
today that not every American is
following it and so this is really a
call to action we see Spain we see Italy
we see France we see Germany when we see
others beginning to bend their curves we
can bend ours but it means everybody has
to take that same responsibility as
America you naughty Americans you
naughty naughty me this is all your
fault you know the curve isn't
flattening and it's your fault says dr.
Burks in her in her nightly lecture you
see if the curve doesn't flatten it
couldn't possibly be because the
strategy that she has suggested is wrong
right now I can't be that can't be yet
the strategy can't be ineffective hey it
can't be you can't and it can't be that
the models that they're using might be
wrong
built on faulty assumptions using bad
data that can't be it no never that
never that you see you see it's it's
it's it's you you're the problem you're
the naughty child you dumb peon you're
the problem you're screwing it up not
the bureaucrats okay it's all it's all
you it's always going to be you because
because under understand this the people
in charge the people doing all of this
calling the shots they will never ever
ever ever ever accept blame for anything
ever
nothing will ever be their fault they're
not gonna stand up there and say we got
this wrong we apologize it's not going
to happen no matter how
at fault they are they won't accept that
they're always gonna shift the blame to
you and me and us and it works because
they've got Americans sniping at each
other calling the cops on their own
neighbors for being outside for the
wrong reason screaming at each other
while the politicians of bureaucrats
whose incompetence caused this mess
escape without blame they get the point
the figure over the finger the finger
over at the the rabble the mob and say
it's all that look at them listen Burke
s'en fout you seem like nice people I'm
sure they're very smart in in their
fields of expertise I'm sure they know
much more than I do in those areas so we
should certainly go to them for advice
and insight into the virus itself and
how it behaves again that we shouldn't
even even on that subject
we shouldn't appoint them as the
official the the official single
authorities but there are two big
problems as far as I can tell with what
we're doing right now and how we're
approaching this and how we're utilizing
these experts number one like like we've
already covered these these people know
nothing about the economic and
constitutional implications of the
policies they recommend and they made it
clear that those implications are
irrelevant not important mere
inconveniences in their minds you know
this is all a matter of avoiding risk
medical risk specifically and preventing
the most number of people from dying
from the virus right now that's what
they're trying to do they don't want you
to die from the virus right now now if
people die from other things brought on
by a great depression that's not their
concern if you know people if people die
because they can't get basic food and
shelter because I can't afford it or
they die from suicide or drugs or drug
overdoses because they've been locked
down and they're losing all their
livelihood and they're they're falling
into despair that's that's the doctors
aren't concerned about that that's not
there they're not focused on stopping
those deaths and if the virus comes back
later and ravages our society once we
open things up
and we're all impoverished and it comes
back again in the middle of a depression
so now we have a pandemic and a
depression on our hands well that's not
so much their concern either
their their goal is to stop people from
dying from this right now and the
general suffering and misery and loss of
liberty and destruction of our way of
life none of that is their concern
because this is not by the way this is
not just we focus so much on the deaths
how do we save the most number of people
it's not just that there are other
things too right suffering and misery
and destroying and destroying someone's
business taking away everything they've
worked for that might not be a death a
physical death but it's still very
important but the question is why are we
letting them essentially set the policy
set the course steer the whole ship when
they're only looking at this one narrow
aspect of the overall crisis why do we
have them on TV every single day telling
us what to do delivering lectures making
decrees and not other experts why can't
we hear from an economic expert to give
us projections on what's going to happen
when this with this great depression
that that's coming up why can't we hear
from a constitutional law expert as far
as Falchi is concerned it's becoming
clear that from his perspective we
should stay locked in our homes under
house arrest until there's a vaccine
because that's how to prevent the most
people from dying of the disease maybe
now it's also how you cut early
annihilate our civilization and ruin
every single thing that makes this
country great makes this country what it
is or was Falchi would throw all of that
on the burn pile if it was up to him but
it shouldn't be up to him because he's
not the president and it shouldn't even
be up to the president because the
president is a president and not a
dictator second thing second issue I
have with the medical experts in the
government extending beyond Falchi and
Burks this isn't just about them it's
also not just about the medical experts
I mean politicians bureaucrats in
general all these people the government
generally my issue here is that they're
putting it all on us blaming us
lecturing us telling us that we have to
give up our jobs our Liberty our income
they're not giving up any of these
things by the way they still have a job
they still have an income they
all the freedom in the world in fact
they have more freedom they have more
power so they're giving nothing up we
give up the power income job everything
lifestyle we give that up they give up
nothing let's be clear about that
these people who are on TV the people in
government they're giving up nothing
it's all on us when they talk about
shared sacrifice no no we're the ones
making the sacrifice
now the actual doctors and surgeons that
are in the hospitals they're making a
huge sacrifice of course but the
politicians of bureaucrats are
sacrificing anything they're fine
that their job is secure everything is
secure for them you know what I haven't
seen from any of these people
accountability responsibility we're
supposed to trust them implicitly do
everything they say even though they
screwed up they screwed up majorly
repeatedly catastrophic ly and now
they're destroying the economy and our
lives to cover their own asses all this
destruction the economy it is a cui a
cover-your-ass move by the government
and we don't even get so much as an
apology from them not even so much is
that like a AG sorry think about this
from December to February while
coronavirus was taking hold in China
over 700,000 travelers from China
entered this country want to say that
again from December to February 700,000
travelers from China were allowed to
enter this country the very government
officials who let 700,000 travelers from
China into this country now want you to
know that the curve isn't flattening and
it's your fault and also trust
everything they say of course they were
too stupid to prevent three-quarters of
a million of people from China from
coming into this country but trust them
now they know what's up you don't don't
trust yourself right you can't trust
yourself that's why we have to shut down
the whole economy because when I when I
have suggested so many times and so many
others have suggested other ways that we
could deal with this you know still have
the economy going but quarantine the
elderly the sick practice practice still
this version of social distancing hi
good hygiene wash your hands wear masks
even a homemade mask where appropriate
and what I'm told about that is yeah we
can't do that go so good we can't trust
people people are stupid they won't
follow it they won't follow those rules
okay so we can't trust ourselves we
can't trust our neighbor we can't trust
these people
we can't trust these people we see on TV
every night the government officials we
can trust them do you trust them more
than you trust yourself
do you trust their models and
projections more than you trust your own
common sense
I don't also consider this as recently
as a month ago the government was
telling us don't wear masks don't wear
them the Surgeon General sent out a sent
out a snarky tweet okay not that long
ago saying seriously people don't wear
matte in all caps stop wearing masks
it's not effective shouting at us
belittling us you you [ __ ] stop wearing
masks
well turns out masks are effective we
should have been wearing them and they
knew it that it doesn't have to be and
you know we don't have to say well yeah
we can't wear medical masses of them
we're taking them away from the medical
professionals who need it yeah homemade
masks put a start over your face it's
better than nothing it's a lot better
than nothing
they knew that okay and they lied to us
for our own good of course for our own
good because you know why they lied to
us because I couldn't trust us because
if they said yeah you know what masks
actually probably will we'll help you
not get sick then they were worried we
would all run out and start hoarding
medical masks now they can't trust us so
they're gonna lie to us again I asked
can we trust them we can't trust
ourselves at all apparently we're a
bunch of idiots we trust them because
that's the problem if you endorse the
idea of the government lying to us
because we can't be trusted what you're
saying is we can definitely trust them
100% we can trust them so much that they
can withhold the truth from us or lie
about it and we can just trust their
judgment on what truth we need to hear
or should hear how many people
because of those lies but now shut down
the economy give up your job on their
word at their command and the models
they're using the models have changed
time and again have been proven false
have been Bates based on bad data bad
assumptions so they come up with new
models never taking any responsibility
for the old models failing they say
there aren't that when we hear about
there not being enough masks enough
ventilators enough hospital beds well
whose fault is that
whose fault is that it's not my fault
it's not your fault
we we're not responsible for their not
being enough medical masks how what were
you supposed to do about that
it's not even China's fault we pay
people in government to take care of
these things and they failed of course
every single individual government
official that's asked about this it's
not what not my fault no no no no sorry
my fault it's that look at them over
there no no not us today no in fact you
notice it's all the dumb Americans who
are buying all the medical masses when
they don't need them well in fact it
turns out they do need them in fact many
of the medical experts now given godlike
powers to reshape society in their image
these are the same people who are
supposed to have us prepared for this
and failed but rather than be held
responsible rather than be tarred and
feathered in the street like we probably
used to like well like we would have
handled it in the old days they get more
power they get rewarded with more power
for being incompetent that's what
happens in government now they fail
they're incompetent they screw up and
the reward is more power for them and so
many of us go along with it by turning
to each other and blaming each other
Tucker Carlson
I mean even the stuff like with the
toilet paper all of this snarky sniping
that we did about people hoarding toilet
paper first of all once the run on
toilet paper had started it made a lot
of sense to go out and get toilet paper
because you need it I mean the thing is
I've been to the store several times and
several different stores over the Co
over the course of this quarantine for
things that I need I haven't seen toilet
paper anywhere now as it happens we did
stock up until the paper not in a
panicked way but if we hadn't we
wouldn't have any right now you know I
got a family of six we need toilet paper
now so we all look at each other in like
laughs at each other what are you doing
buying toilet paper well cuz I need it
you [ __ ] what do you think I need it
it's nowhere to be found but yet again I
put that on the government they should
have had us better prepared they should
have you know rather than say because
here's what the government did the
government went from this is nothing
this is nothing this is nothing don't
worry about it - all of a sudden it's
the end of the world like there was a
sudden change and with that sudden
change people panicked and they started
running out and buying things now if if
the government had been honest and on
top of this since like December and it
started saying you know here's what's
going on it is a it's a concern
it's not the end of the world but we're
gonna start taking measures there would
have been a gradual thing a gradual
awareness that would have been raised
among the people and things will be very
different right now Tucker Carlson made
this point on a show yesterday I think
it's a good point if two months ago
three months ago if we had started
quarantine in the nursing homes the
elderly the sick had people wearing
masks even homemade ones there would be
far fewer dead by now we would still
have an economy we wouldn't have ten
million jobs lost in two weeks their
medical experts who should have been
recommending those steps back then
didn't instead they were saying don't
wear masks don't worry about the virus
it's not a threat they were wrong they
were catastrophic ly wrong and now they
get to shut down society and take your
job and your livelihood and your home
and your food out of your
frig to cover their tracks and if all
this doesn't work if it backfires which
it will it already is still not gonna be
their fault never there's never ever
there's let's move to headlines number
one the governor of New Jersey in an
effort to one-up the other governors
around him has made a rather striking
suggestion listen if you do not need to
be out then we need you to stay at home
please God stay at home and even when
you're at home
keep your distance between yourself and
other family members what what what was
that you want us to you want us to
socially distance from each other at
home that you see there's a competition
going on here don't you each governor
tries to be the one taking it the most
seriously so we go from shutdowns to
Northam locking down the whole state for
two months to now New Jersey saying oh
yeah well we're locking down the state
and we're gonna say you can't go near
your own family it is good advice though
because in fact kids don't respect
personal space at all and so I've had to
call my I've had to call the police on
my kids four times today already to
report them for infringing on my
personal space on my protective bubble
it's all about being a good citizen but
fortunately I can't say my
three-year-old was given just a five
thousand dollar fine which you know not
a big deal
they're only taken a few decades of
allowance to be able to pay that though
my six-year-old twins are facing sixty
days in jail so that's you know that's
that's unfortunate but this is what
happens number two and the competition
of course continues with now Vermont
throwing its hat into the ring Vermont
is ordering retailers essential
retailers quote-unquote in the state to
stop selling non-essential items so
Vermont is going to tell you what you're
allowed to sell and reading from
wcvb.com according to the state large
retailers must cease in-person sales of
items that include but are not limited
to arts and crafts beauty supplies
carpet and flooring clothing consumer
electronics entertainment furniture home
and garden jewelry paint photo services
sports equipment toys
States says that continuous as the state
says stores must restrict access to
non-essential goods by closed aisles by
closing aisles closing portions of the
store or removing items from the floor
the order says showrooms and garden
sections of large home improvement
centers should be closed okay maybe at
this point the government should just
come up with an official list an
official shopping list for us maybe they
can assign maybe the government can
assign us all a shopping list every week
telling us what to buy right down to the
specific food items and brands and
everything so I needed to be really
specific like tell me exactly what type
of canned pasta sauce I can buy what are
the non-essential pasta sauces versus
the essential ones that's what I want to
know we can't have people going out and
buying non-essential ragu okay and which
soda which soda brand is essential
obviously you know like 7up for sprite
sprites gonna be essential not 7up Coke
or Pepsi which is the essential one
that's and that's that's a real
controversy but you would think this is
a matter of opinion just like you would
think a lot of these essential versus
non-essential designations are a matter
of opinion and they are but the
government's opinion is what matters
trust whatever they say basically the
goal here is to remove all personal
choice from individuals because we're
too stupid and we're too encountered we
need the guiding hand of government to
come in and direct every last aspect of
our lives now of course people in
government are dumber and even less
competent than we are but there that's
fine because they're in the government
so they know best number three this is
very interesting professor bhakti a
microbiologist has written an open
letter to the Chancellor of Germany but
really it could've been written to any
Western world leader and he has a number
of questions about the corona virus that
he's asking raising several interesting
points and it's worth reading whole
thing go to daily wire.com and they've
got an article about it's worth reading
the whole thing but let me read this
this particular section of his letter he
says the mistake is being made worldwide
worldwide to report virus related deaths
as soon as it is established that the
virus was present at the time of death
regardless of other
factors this violates the principles of
only when it is certain that an agent
has played a significant role that
disease or death may a diagnosis be made
the Association of the scientific
medical societies of Germany expressly
rights in its guidelines in addition to
the cause of death a causal chain must
be stated with the corresponding
underlying disease in third place on the
death certificate occasionally for
linked causal chains must also be stated
at present there is no official
information on whether at least in
retrospect more critical analyses of
medical records have been undertaken to
determine how many deaths were actually
caused by the virus okay what are you
saying her point is we know so many of
these deaths are attributed to the virus
among previously ill people we keep
hearing that you know people in their
80s and 90s dying people who have
pre-existing conditions dying okay well
if somebody with the virus and terminal
cancer for example dies do we call that
a virus death or a cancer death because
my understanding I don't know the answer
to this question but my understanding of
it is at least in normal times if
somebody has terminal cancer and they
let's say contract pneumonia and die
what we what we usually will say is they
succumbed to cancer or they lost the
battle with cancer or something like
that you know when some of the terminal
cancer eventually dies of something
related to the fact that they had cancer
we don't we don't usually we wouldn't
say he died of pneumonia we would just
say he died of cancer so what are we
doing here if someone dies and the cause
isn't clear but they have the virus do
we automatically assume they died of it
is dying with the virus the same as
dying from it as far as the way it's
categorized it's a good question in fact
I saw I saw a really tragic terrible
headline maybe you saw this of I think
it was a six week old baby who died just
horrifying but the headlines that I saw
so I looked at several headlines in
several news articles because I was
trying to figure this out right and the
headline said baby with coronavirus dies
or
baby discovered to have coronavirus dyes
like something like that baby's death
linked to coronavirus like those are the
headlines that's very strange isn't it
it's just a strange way of putting it
and I read about five or six different
articles about this particular case and
I'm trying to find out did they do an
autopsy and that what the results came
back and they found that the corona
virus was the cause of the death maybe
like I don't know but it seems that for
right now as far as we know the baby had
coronavirus and tragically died but you
put it in the headlines with the
assumption that the baby died from
corona virus and this is not a small
thing okay and the problem is that when
someone like myself tries to make this
point we're accused of being cruel or
heartless or what have you that's that's
the opposite of the case but what I'm
saying is in the media it is malpractice
to terrify people to terrify mothers and
fathers who have babies put that in the
headlines without without doing without
making sure that the virus is actually
what caused the death
you're just terrifying people and and
you're doing it for cliques that's why
it's not because you care about the
child or you're concerned about it no
you put it in the headlines phrased that
way rather than the responsible thing is
to wait to find out what caused the
death and then to report on it but you
don't wait you put it up right away not
because you care about the child
far from it it's because you're
exploiting the child's death to get
clicks and to scare people and the
reason you want to scare people is
because it means more clicks and more
attention and more ratings number four
different industries are finding ways to
adapt to the new reality you'd think
that one industry that would have have
trouble is the the clubbing industry
DJ's who play at nightclubs so
specifically what are they going to do
well they're trying to adapt and so now
we've got something called cloud
clubbing which means that DJ's are doing
their thing there their DJ thing playing
music and they'll stream it for people
to listen to in their homes so they're
broad they're doing the DJ then they're
broadcasting it to people around
call that we call that cloud clubbing
now I read that and I think okay so
you've invented the radio is what you've
done this is the radio right this is a
DJ in one place you've invented music
ready you've invented rock radio
congratulations it's a DJ in one place
playing music that is broadcast to other
people in other places that's that's
basically what the radio does different
technology but that's I guess we could
just call it cloud clubbing from now on
any time you turn on the radio doing a
little cloud clubbing number five
finally I want to show you this a bit of
a visual so if you're if you're
listening on iTunes right now or
SoundCloud or whatever you'll have to
when you get a chance go check out the
stream of this show so you can look at
this visual because it really does lend
perspective this is a graft a graph I
should say made by a guy on Twitter
whose handle is at startup Damon and it
shows it shows the weekly jobless claims
starting in the 60s let me let me just
we'll play this alright so it starts
late in the sixties go to the 70s you
see the jobless claims weekly 90s goes
up and down like you would expect you
have Peaks and then we're gonna see a
big spike around 2010 there we go with
the recession and then now we get to now
and look at that okay up up up up up up
up up up up up
keeps going keeps going keeps climbing
and there it is there's there's the last
cut that's the last couple of weeks of
jobless claims that's what we've done
this is what we've done in our country
but don't worry dr. Falchi just an
inconvenience what you saw there in the
chart bunch of inconveniences nothing
more okay now we're gonna move to our
daily cancelation it gives me great joy
and pleasure to cancel Mayor Bill
DeBlasio of New York a man who is less a
man really than a sniveling oh fish
troll and easily one of the most
incompetent clowns to ever hold major
elected office in the United States
which is a hell of a bar to get over I'd
realize but he has succeeded
here's exhibit a actually it's like
exhibit Z I don't know there been a lot
of exhibits of this but anyway reading
from the blaze it says evangelist
Franklin Graham's charity organization
Samaritan's Purse opened up a temporary
tent hospital in Central Park
to help treat patients infected with
kovat 19 but New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio doesn't trust the organization
not to discriminate against LGBTQ
patients faith wire reported Samaritan's
Purse set up a facility with 68 beds for
the core no virus patients an attempt to
ease the burden of overwhelmed hospitals
de Blasio expressed distrust that the
organization would treat LGBTQ people
equally and reportedly sent city
staffers to the site to monitor the
situation
de Blasio said according to New York
Post I said immediately to my team that
we had to find out exactly what was
happening was there going to be an
approach that was truly consistent with
the values and laws of New York City
that everyone could be served and it
would be served and serve equally we've
received those assurances from the
organization we're going to send people
over from the mayor's office to monitor
I'm very concerned that this is done
right but if it is done right we need
all the help we can get okay now just so
you know there was of course never any
reason to think never any evidence never
any indication at all this organization
was going to discriminate against
anybody so the only thing what what
concerns bill de blasio is that it's a
Christian organization that's what
concerns him he's very concerned
I'm staff very concerned of Christians
Christian now Christians are showing up
on the scene Christians are showing up
on the scene like they always show up
every time there's a catastrophe or
disaster people are in need there's
always Christians showing up so bill de
blasio must be concerned a lot he must
be you know anytime there's a crisis he
must be very very concerned because of
all these all these sneaky little
Christians who show up what are they
doing around here it couldn't be that
they're you know that they're following
Christ's command to help those in need
and it could be that there's gotta be
something there's there's a there's of
some sinister motivation and it must be
something sinister and so de Blasio is
concerned and he sends his goons out to
monitor they're in the middle of a
crisis and de Blasio is allocating
resources to make sure that Hospital
workers are being sufficiently
progressive and woke in the fulfillment
of their medical
responsibilities think about that so
bill de blasio a well-deserving
cancellation
okay now I want to briefly tell you
about a couple other things still to do
on the show first of all the all-access
show I wanted to tell you about that you
know we've been we've been talking about
it and more and more people are joining
in for the all-access live show we do an
8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. central we do it
every single night at least every
weeknight now and it's probably not
always gonna be the way originally the
idea was to do it every once in a while
just for our all-access members but
we've we've rolled we've moved up to
date we've opened it up to all daily
wire members just because in the middle
of this national emergency people are
locked in their homes and need a little
bit of a little bit of companionship we
all do a discussion being able to talk
to someone who's not immediately in your
house with you is kind of nice as well
and so that's what we've been doing it's
been I think I think the feedback has
been great people have enjoyed it I've
enjoyed it so make sure you tune in
today at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. central
now moving on to emails as we wrap up
the show for a Friday remember you can
email the show if you become a daily
wire remember you can submit emails to
the mailbag this is from Chuck says
during your show on Wednesday you took
issue with the government lying to the
public by saying masks don't really help
so don't worry about wearing one took
issue with the today so I've taken issue
with it several times then then they
came out later and said yeah that was
kind of wrong we didn't we don't want to
cause panic and hoarding I'm not saying
this was right or wrong good or bad I
just want to pose a couple of questions
as food for thought have you ever lied
to your kids for their own good and
maybe your own good as well something
you knew if you told the truth about it
it would either end up badly for one of
you or they just flat-out wouldn't get
it now you might say but they are
children were adults it's not the same
to that I would direct your attention to
idiots licking toilet seats toiletries
and tubs of ice cream or drinking beer
off each others butts on the beach or
any one of a hundred other things people
mostly young people might do to spread
this and other diseases they have the
facts they know this is risky behavior
but they do it anyway now if there was a
lied to tell that would get them to stop
that nonsense should it be told I just
wanted to hear your opinion and get a
learned man's perspective I'm not really
a learning man so if you want to learn
in man's perspective you got to talk to
somebody else you got the wrong man for
that what I guess I already sort of
addressed that earlier in the show I
just know I don't think the government
should be lying to us for our own good
or because they're afraid of what we
would do with the truth now I'm not
saying that every everything that is
true the government should come out and
say obviously there's a classified
information about various different
things that they're not going to tell us
about so so of course that's one thing
but first of all whether or not but what
weather masks are effective in the
middle of pandemic that should not be
classified information and besides it's
not just that they withheld the
information they flat-out lied and said
it's not effective don't do it when it
is effective and you should do it and
these are so-called medical experts
right it's not like they just learned
that method medical masks are effective
it never made us it never made sense to
begin with because they were saying
they're not effective don't wear them oh
by the way also we need to save them for
doctors because if doctors don't have it
it's a big crisis well if they're not
effective why do doctors wear them right
so clearly never made sense to begin
with and they didn't believe it no
should the government be be withholding
the information or lying to us because
of because of the idiots who lick toilet
seats and so on no no because no because
it's wrong first of all and we live
we're supposed to live in a free country
and in a free country you don't have a
government or you shouldn't have a
government we shouldn't tolerate a
government that tells us lies for our
own good and the third thing as I
mentioned these people are idiots - okay
who do you think these people in
government are a lot of them were
probably toilet-seat liquors when they
were younger so sort or worse right so
these are a bunch of morons also in
government so if we can't trust the the
rabble the mob why can we trust them
remember they came from the rabble they
came from the mob they just were they
were appointed by the rabble and the mob
some of them were the bureaucrats
weren't appointed by any will certainly
weren't elected by the mob were but were
appointed by the people that the mob
elected so if you can't trust the mob
you can't trust them either there they
came from the same pool so I absolutely
reject that I think in especially now we
need information we need the truth you
need to be honest with people and it
makes you think what else are they lying
about it a Rhodes trust in our governing
in our in our rulers which we shouldn't
have rulers but we do in a row
trust and then you start thinking what
else are they lying about what what what
other lies for our own good are they
telling us J says hi Matt can you please
explain why the coronavirus is different
economically than the world wars or the
twentieths or the of the 20th century
assume that means world wars of the 20th
century it seems in both cases economic
and domestic life was paused while the
nation dealt with a common mission to
defeat an eminent enemy in both cases
the subsequent decades has significant
economic growth and expansion this can
be attributed to the pent-up consumer
demand as well as a flood of labor back
into the workforce I'm scared like
everybody about the oblique economic
outlook at the moment but I'm curious
why the same principles don't apply here
[Music]
well I think for a number of reasons
first of all with with a war with any
war the economy doesn't go on pause life
doesn't go on pause now there may be
significant resources that are put into
fighting the war which can be a good or
bad thing depending on the war if we're
talking about the analysts never ending
war in Afghanistan it's a bad thing
world war 2 good thing right so
resources are allocated there people
people in the world and you you lose a
lot of workers because they're going
overseas to fight many of them die so
that's the case yeah but that's very
different I would say from the
government telling you to stay in your
homes and not do any work with it with a
war everyone's doing work and you might
be doing different work than you were
doing before especially if you the work
you were doing before was you were
working at a factory or something and
now you're now you're overseas fighting
the Nazis that's very different work but
that's just it's allocating the
resources differently here we're just
telling you there's no allocation the
allocation is stay in your homes you're
not you're not allowed to leave this is
the government saying is it's shutting
down the economy not not directing the
economy towards a war effort but
shutting it down completely so this is a
very different thing and it's also it is
unprecedented now people will point out
some of the measures that were taken in
some areas during for example the
Spanish flu epidemic 100 years ago but
that was not anything
like the scale that we have now where
you have the entire country shut down to
my knowledge that did not happen
it's not ever happened certainly not in
modern history and we should also keep
in mind that back then the government
wasn't twenty trillion dollars in debt
and spending even more to try to to try
to buy its way out of this eka this
upcoming economic depression so I would
say it's a it's a different now just
because it's unprecedented and different
than anything that's been done before
doesn't make it wrong automatically it
is wrong to be to do what they're doing
but that's not what makes it wrong
necessarily but it's I just don't think
those comparisons hold up so thanks for
that I think we'll leave it there thanks
everyone for watching have a have a
great try to have a try to have a good
weekend you know at least around here
the weather is nice so you can least go
outside if your state if your state
allows you for an approved reason you
can exit your home
and enjoy did you enjoy nature at least
for small amounts of time and so I hope
you enjoy that we'll talk on Monday
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there